[Musik]
leute ganz kurz aus weiter weg abonniert
auf jeden fall den kanal es fehlen noch
ungefähr 35 abonnenten bis zu eine
million
das wäre super cool würde ich nicht
richtig freuen vielleicht schaffen wir
ja dass noch dieses jahr und s42 und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
gerne hätte ich auch natürlich euch
jedes gut tut mir erst mal leicht
gestern kam leider kein video ich war
drei tage lang zusammen und gestern war
rückreisetag und ich hasse ich geschafft
also hab's halt nicht geschafft das war
leider auch kein video mehr vor
produziert also müssen uns jetzt wieder
ran habe mir damit auch jeden tag um 19
uhr ein wiederkommen
weißt du was hast du schon mal so ein
outfit gesehen ist man auch keinen stolz
pfingsten einmal zeigen sieht man dass
deine hose scripta ich weiß das war
innerhalb verschiedener auch nicht nur
das kommt die socken passen einfach zum
oberteil untersuchen
das liefert also was genau ganz wichtig
deswegen schenkt auf jeden fall war das
10 kostenlose produkte check das ab
leute ich habe mir folgendes vorgenommen
für diese woche oder was ich auf jeden
fall auf testen wollte und zwar haben
wir das auch sehr viele geschrieben wir
hatten ja jetzt war zirka zwei wochen
einmal diese airports pro die ja neu
herausgekommen sind mit dem noise
cancelling das mich sehr fasziniert hat
und daraufhin haben sehr viele leute
geschrieben von huawei gibt es auch
sogenannte free mazda ich jetzt vor ein
paar wochen ich glaub auch erst im
november wenn nicht sogar gerade mal vor
einer woche die dritte version
rausgekommen
wir haben hier nämlich die vorwahl
freezers 3 new intelligence sound für
180 euro
also ich habe da wirklich 180 euro für
bezahlt auch nicht günstig
trotzdem war es mir das geld auf jeden
fall für ein youtube-video wert wir
werden die man testen und ich bin
gespannt ob die mich überzeugen
und ob ich dann am ende sagen wollt euch
lieber die als die airports pro ich
werde jetzt direkt mal aufmachen
natürlich wird sicherlich ein paar
unterschiede geben also ich sehe schon
die sind vom design
also die jeweils an sich sind er sodann
halt wie die airports zu ersten und
zweiten generation und natürlich nicht
sowie die airports pro die waren ja so
ein bisschen kürzer auch vom case total
anders und die hatten vorher noch diese
ohrmuschel die ins ohr eingehen und das
ist jetzt auch nicht der fall also
dadurch dass die kopfhörer dann wirklich
so weit ins ohr gehen hat man halt ganz
mehr von der umgebung wahrgenommen fand
ich und ob das hier auch so ist mache
ich zu bezweifeln aber wir finden es
heute natürlich raus techno auf den
sound checken meinetwegen auch das
mikrofon und auch die distanz wobei das
hier eigentlich unnötig ist das wird sie
funktionieren da bin ich mir sicher ich
mein 180 euro ist ja auch eine ansage
die müssen ja etwas können so jetzt habe
ich schon wenn nur gelabert okay ich bin
mal gespannt ob ich die am ende dann
verlosen wir haben bei den airports vor
gesagt wenn das video innerhalb von
vierundzwanzig schon 10000 lux hat dann
verlor sich die auf einem instagram
account das video hatte leider nur 8900
ich habe es auf die stunde genau
kontrolliert und deswegen wurden die
leiter nicht verloren aber ich sag mal
so
vielleicht machen wir gleich noch mal
10.000 24 stunden dann verlor sich die
auf dem instrument account alter spiel
gar nicht die verpackung zerstören aber
süchtig vorsichtig inhalte jetzt
reicht's mir jetzt also glücklich man
schon noch werden auch eine sehr große
verpackungen
das muss man sagen doppelt so groß wie
bei den airports huawei um und jetzt
klappt man das auch wir wie so ein buch
und hier haben wir dann auch schon das
produkt um das ist
heute geht ich habe ganz kurz hier
trotzdem meine eigenen airports geholt
der ersten generation die der zweiten
generation sind eigentlich genauso aus
um da vielleicht auch gleich mal
designtechnisch so ein paar vergleiche
zu ziehen die axpo habe ich ja nicht
mehr gut
dann haben wir noch hier drinnen
wahrscheinlich ladekabel und auch in der
beschreibung okay die beschreibung ist
schon so ein bisschen ähnlich eingepackt
in chinesisch atem an ich habe die im
media markt gekauft meinst du hier ist
einfach trotzdem keine deutsche
beschreibung bei das glaube ich nicht
oder
okay ein ganz bisschen deutsch steht
hier in dem buch schon drin allerdings
dieses hier ist nur auf englisch und
chinesisch und ich glaube das ist das
was wir brauchen werden um das ganze
system dahinter zu verstehen weil da
gibt es natürlich auch verschiedene
funktionen wenn man hier zwei mal drauf
tippt wird wohl dieses neues cancelling
aktiviert und so weiter
naja zum lkw in der schule englisch
gelernt und hier haben wir jetzt noch
das kamen aber kummer war damals das ist
doch ist halt verpackt vielleicht haben
ja ja und es ist ja auch so ein comeback
des 40 kann ich mit denen lampen zu
diesen kabbeln sich gar nichts mehr ist
immer falsch
also das ist jetzt ein mini mini usb
kabel oder was gucken ich so sagt du
weißt es doch sagt ich weiß nicht aber
wie kommt es dass er auch dieses mal was
anderes das heißt doch heute bei der
neuen black box dass der anschluss der
100 jetzt lag doch nicht so du kannst du
weißt es doch fraktion die kommentare
heute und schreibt noch dazu auf jeden
fall ist das mein erstes ladekabel was
so aus irgendwann ist immer das erste
mal so jetzt reicht's auch hier und wir
ziehen das thema vorsichtig ab und
machen die aus willich das fühlt sich
geil an alter okay die sind schon so ein
bisschen verkrüppelt aus sie erinnert
mich ein bisschen an die g7 tws glaube
ich an ihn erinnern mich an die action
dinge weiß was ich meine
habe ich leider nicht mehr aber die vom
action die sagen so ein bisschen hier
und guckt sie das machen gerade nicht
frage ist jetzt natürlich sind die
aufgeladen oder nicht ich hole trotzdem
hier kurz meine airports als vergleich
gemacht und ich drehe das ganze jetzt
mal um
eigentlich ja schon deutlicher
unterschied zu erkennen und vom case ja
sowieso immer
kannst du das huawei gelesen das
spiegelt so ein bisschen ich kann es
jetzt von oben lesen kannst es auch
nicht als muster an paket an dem so ok
war stehengeblieben ist jetzt auch egal
ich will jetzt gar nicht lange rum
labern studie jetzt machen mein ohr
irgendwie irritiert mich dass hier so
ein bisschen dass die so nach oben gehen
weißt du dass dir dieser bockel ist und
ich muss auch sagen die sitzen nicht so
perfekt im ohr wie es meine position das
kann natürlich auch sein dass das
gewohnheitssache ist aber ich habe hier
ist ein bisschen mehr das gefühl dass
ihr held leicht herausfallen können oder
leichter ausfallen können naja man muss
nur so machen und hier ist es wirklich
dass sie richtig drin sind also deutlich
stärkeren wenn ihr versteht was ich
meine täglichen scheiße nur kurz zu
beschreiben chatten tschuldigung ich
habe mich vertan und blowfish ich dachte
eigentlich sie haben wir irgendwie dann
so eine touch funktion vielleicht dass
das angeht aber habe ich mich geehrt
werden als hier an der seite an auch
diesen button um das case hat praktisch
zu starten und wahrscheinlich dann auch
um eine bluetooth verbindung herstellen
zu können und jetzt bringt sie halt auch
schön drin also ja das ziel doch geil
aus oder kann hat man aus wie smooth das
geht
ich bin echt mal gespannt wie so in fünf
jahren dieser smartphone markt aussieht
weiß ob in deutschland immer noch so
apple diese high class marke ist oder
wie sich das entwickelt also mal schauen
deswegen macht es sehr viel spaß solche
sachen auszuprobieren und die fangen an
zu blinken können das heißt wir können
sie jetzt kollekten und tauchen
natürlich direkt auf platz drei
ich frage mich echt mittlerweile so
alles was sich neue auspacke
funktioniert denn direkt richtig gut
also direkt ist die connection dar
wir hatten am anfang immer probleme der
haben
eine halbe stunde lang gesessen ist es
überhaupt mal geklappt hat ok hiergegen
von verbunden
jetzt tue ich die mainz ohr und macht
direkt mal
oder habe ich finde wirklich die liegen
nicht so leistung oder das ist schon mal
ein bisschen scheiße aber sonst machen
wir direktoren soundcheck hast du den
song ich heute ist juli nicht so
gesprächig ich weiß was du selber nach
musik nennt also doch ich musik höre ja
dasselbe ich mache dieses jahres selber
an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also es klingt absolut gut deswegen
wirklich gut aber ich glaube es ist
nicht so gut also meine persönliche wahl
muss erstmal das ist nicht so gut
klingen wie bei den airports dass da
irgendwie so ein bisschen dafür da fehlt
irgendwie was aber ist klingt so ein
bisschen so ein bisschen so ganz leicht
bisschen übersteuern war das schiff zu
erklären du musst auch einmal hören als
musikexperten brüder hast du drin
du hast 3321 darf meine eigenen sachen
ja jetzt wird hier von julia eigens
produzierte song gehört dein eigener
sollten dann wieder heißt ist noch nicht
raus sonst haben 512 live gegen
bootshaus oder 66 kommt vor gericht
also ich finde sie gut findet nicht
besser als airports aber gut wenn nicht
besser klappt auf jeden fall ist jetzt
das zweitbeste von einige tests aber
airport sind immer noch besser ist auch
meine persönliche wahrnehmung und komma
der hat gar keinen sensor so dass die
merken heil wenn sie im ohr sind und
nicht weißt du weil bei der post docs
hier automatisch
naja ok jetzt habe ich hier gerade
gesehen wir haben diese noise cancelling
funktion die ich ja wirklich noch kurz
testen wollte also vom sound her
airports pro ein gedicht die hier gut
knapp dran also ja knapp dran wobei klar
erfolgskurs in europa 100 euro teurer
aber auch diese hier sind vom sound her
bei double cab the left ear buds jbl on
the table active noise cancelling
abgekürzt
ok mach ich mal bei dem projekt gehe es
ja auch ohne musik noise cancelling okay
hörst du mich heute schon also es ist
überhaupt nicht so krass die beiden
airports pro gar nicht also ich also ich
hörte eine stimme etwas abgedämpft so
aber ich habe auch hier auf meine neuen
song ganz leichtes rauschen und das ist
ja nicht gut ich mache mir sorgen
ja was soll ich jetzt sage einfach
schneidet das aber nicht mehr so ein
also irgendwie mit ganz kleinen
unterschied ob man da war aber es ist
jetzt überhaupt nichts krasses so also
ich bin mir sicher ich würde immer noch
die schreienden kinder im flugzeug oder
in der bahn fahren oder hier oder die
ihr genau chance und überzeugte die
bauarbeiter die ihr seid unten hinken
schild das die zum 15 11 wollten die
fertig sein die immer noch in die am
25.11 allerdings erst mal erwischt werde
also klar mit noise cancelling kann man
wahrscheinlich auch gut werden und es
hört sich erst mal cool an allerdings
ist es überhaupt nicht so intensiv wie
bei der osg natürlich habe ich das am
anfang auch schon vermutet weil wir halt
keine muschel haben die aktiv ins ohr
geht und somit nicht viel staat
abgedeckt werden kann aber gut
ach das ist doch auf deutsch
unterrichtet nun auf den 3d und alter
ich muss man mal die augen aufmacht und
ich würde sagen wir können auch kurze
mikrofon check machen und das war's dann
auch schon
und dann kann ich doch schon ein fazit
ziehen und die eventuelle verlosen
also was machst du denn hier ja sagt man
muss ja ich bin noch hier in meinem
zimmer und marie macht irgendwelche
dummen aufgaben rektor für ihre uni
seite stehst du musst du verstehst du
mich jetzt gut aber es ist nicht total
gut ist okay ist standard ist jetzt
nichts wahnsinniges eigentlich warum
hast du die baustelle sehen auch nicht
warum dann doch drin ist okay ihr könnt
ihr mal eure theorie in die kommentare
schreiben warum erhofft sich davon mehr
ist nicht von mir ich hatte 60 euro
kostete damals leute gut kommen wir zum
fazit also ich muss sagen für 179 euro
was ich dafür bezahlt haben meinung nach
viel zu teuer wenn die jetzt 19
kosten wir nur so würde ich vermutlich
noch sagen geil wollte ich dir auf jeden
fall aber diese 179 sind meinung nach zu
viel geld dafür weil wir erstens nicht
so gute soundqualität haben wir bei den
airports der ersten zweiten generation
und auch bei den apples pro aber gut
dass wir noch biologisch 2 ist diese
neue scans link funktion ist absolut
überflüssig drittens in meinem ohr
hängen die nicht so gut fest und fehlen
uns jetzt gerade das telefonat zwischen
uns war haltet in ordnung von der
qualität der arbeit nix nix überzeugung
dass vom mikrofon würde ich mal sagen
also das gesamtpaket stimmt hier auf
jeden fall mehr und ich habe gesehen
ohne große werbung zu machen gibt es
gerade für 165 euro bei mediamarkt
irgendwie so halbwegs im angebot oder
entlang
also die airports zur ersten generation
sind günstiger als diesel friwa trotzdem
an sich coole dinge wenn man jetzt sagt
ey die hätte ich gerne zeigt das video
bei 10.000 verlose ich die auf meine
minister dem account alex wie alle auf
jeden fall folgen morgen dann um diese
uhrzeit post in die story als dieses
video 2006 macht ansonsten sehen wir uns
morgen 19 wieder gibt's neues video
und 23